and then I started working for
non-profits when I'm uh when I was
around 20 years old trying to do
activism I was you know listening all
the punk rock stuff made me very
political started working with
nonprofits thinking like this is the way
we're going to change the world and uh
quickly realize they're just businesses
and they have a bottom line that's all
that really matters in the end for most
of them especially the big ones and then
Occupy Wall Street started I had been
active in the hacker community so this
is where the activist journalist thing
comes in when I started doing this I
didn't care for whatever journalism was
because journalism was corporate
narrative garbage they would ignore what
the truth was we'd have uh you know I'd
have friends who were involved in some
kind of worldly geopolitical action and
the media would just be completely wrong
about it I remember I had a friend who
competed in the X Games the next day in
the front page of the paper completely
wrong about what happened and I'm just
like I don't know whatever that is I'm
not involved with so me you know when I
went down to Occupy Wall Street it was
information activism is what we referred
to it as in the hacker community
collecting and disseminating information
and then I was like oh that's what
journalism was supposed to be you know
so so when you when you get those cross
narratives and then you get a a media
ecosystem that doesn't care for the
Nuance just writes a quick fires it off
you end up with
you know like on Wikipedia it says these
things and it doesn't really explain the
context of how these things end up
happening so you know after like six
months I have these uh journalists say
you realize journalism is literally just
collecting and disseminating information
and I was like oh well I grew up
watching a bunch of people lie on the TV
for special interest so that's what
journalism was to me yeah right and now
it's like oh okay I get that I get that
but with um increasing notoriety from
being acted by Wall Street being on the
ground in uh namely with Berkeley the
conflict between antifa and right-wing
groups I I started gaining too much
attention you know I went and went to
Sweden filmed like a two-week Vlog
covering escalation of crime and stuff
like that and then by the time I'm back
in the United States after a couple
years it's impossible for me to go out
and film anything anymore so this is
maybe like seven or eight years into my
specifically journalistic career I'm
having people run up to me in these
these these moments and instead of me
covering what's happening people are
running up to me and I can't do this
anymore you know they're running up to
you doing what exactly oh man I'm a big
fan it's a great or right up to me and
swinging at me oh great yeah okay one or
the other yeah if I show up here there's
no more story on the story and so I I
can't do it and then that slowly caused
a transformation into commentary podcast
because this is what I would do I would
go down and I would stream the Occupy
Wall Street thing specifically was a 21
hour straight live broadcast
where the park got raided and I was
there 21 hours holding up my phone
people were bringing me batteries to get
my phone from shutting down and uh I'm
doing live commentary in real time as
all this stuff's happening to you know
millions of people how old are you at
the time oh man what was I 25 maybe oh
yeah this is 2009 2011 so yeah it's 25.
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]